the Highlands of Papua New Guinea a
place so remote that the people who live
here are among the most isolated on
earth one of the native tribes the
Matassa practices an ageless ritual so
secret that it has never before been
witnessed by some members of the tribe
much less filmed tomorrow will be the
day of poon a fellows initiation the
stakes are high
a boy may not marry or take on the
privileges of adulthood until he has
completed the right poon A's father
supports his son's decision those who
become too scared to participate
eventually find out that they are less
attractive to women and they don't have
the same energy as others in making
Gardens building houses or walking long
distances they live a miserable life as
bachelors until the time of their death
I am born here to be a man to protect my
family
tribe and my people the most important
thing is to go through the initiation to
realize my role as a man in my community
[Music]
for thousands of years that role was
often brutal traditionally Highland
people lived in a near constant state of
tribal warfare and could be expected to
take part in raids kidnappings murders
and cannibalism at some point in their
adult lives
[Music]
they're painful initiation ritual was
considered essential to transform timid
boys into brave men it is the morning of
the Matassa initiation ceremony along a
sacred creek the elders prepare for the
painful blood Rite just downstream
novices wash and wait it is their
traditional belief that to become men
they must expel the contaminating
influences of women when our mothers
gave birth to us some of their blood
remains in us which is considered
unclean when we do the ritual it helps
get rid of the rubbish that is stored in
our system and purifies us this is the
purpose of the exercise the initiate
were brought forward and see for the
first time the ordeal they face elders
shove several feet of pit pit cane down
the backs of their throats then pull it
out so they retch again and again
then it's the novices turn hunain
empties his stomach into the stream next
to get rid of contaminants they may have
breathed the men Rams sharp Reed's deep
into each other's nostrils
blood and mucus pour freely to complete
their passage into manhood hue and the
others must expose themselves to one
more bloodletting
this time they will cleanse another part
of the body that was exposed to female
polluted food their tongue the
razor-sharp arrow slices tender flesh
again and again poon a steals himself
for his final challenge the right side
to his pain is great my inside to the
outside
finally the stream washes away the last
of their blood and their trials come to
an end they return to the campsite and
their community as men
[Music]